i'm impressed with steve o'sobriety the
one and also impressed with the stunts
he did in the movie steve oh boy he
steps up every time i am so proud of
stevo and his sobriety blown away by it
i mean yeah people call me brave that's
real bravery to uh
to be where he was and to just
face it head-on and uh how'd he do it
johnny willingness he got sober because
he wanted to get sober you can't make
anyone get sober of course we took him
and threw him in we 5150 him but
there had to be a switch in his brain
that said i want to get sober and it
happened while he was inside right and
uh
and to his credit
he stayed sober which is amazing
it's not a given we know it's not a
given he's had to work his ass off to
stay sober all power to that guy and uh
i'm very impressed with him yeah and
he's funny as hell in the movie he's
he's one of those guys you got to see
him in the movie now he held out a
beginning he felt he should get more
money than what the production was
willing to pay him yeah he later
apologized to you for his behavior he
said i think i was a little bit too
vehement in my demands and my
negotiation but he felt he deserved more
money and he did get more money right uh
yeah he got uh he got a a little more
and he got a credit um
but yeah it was it was tense with the
negotiations with stevo and
us
and it got to a point where he was angry
at us and i got a little upset at him
you were upset because he was holding up
the production it was more than that it
got a little
it got a little ugly right and yeah it
got personal and i would like to say
that i could have
handled it better and and stevo's
admitted he could have handled it better
and
you know once we got through the
negotiations he and i had to sit down
and to talk
and
just aired everything out because you
can't go into that with resentments you
can't have resentments on a set
where you're doing things stunts that
your life's on the line everyone has to
be in a positive mood because
you can't be in a negative mood if
anyone's like negative or off and we're
doing something dangerous we bounce them
we balance them from set because you
can't have that lingering but stevo and
i talked and
we love each other and we got through it
and we had a wonderful time on the movie
he's amazing in the movie i'm so proud
of him
every day i'm proud of steve oh